il y a 7 ans une histoire incroyable
explosée sur internet à 22 ans je me
suis retrouvé reprise avec la mafia
russe je faisais un voyage d'étude avec
ma classe Igor sera votre ange gardien
c'est un homme dangereux vous ne devez
pas lui parler ni passer du temps avec
lui bah moi tout ce que je veux c'est
passé du temps avec ce type je parlais
pas un mot de russe il y a ma Chine
tout ce que je t'avais dit c'était
ce fut le plus bel été de ma vie on va
pas voler ce pauvre gars
23 ans après ces événements
l'histoire continue elle est bizarre
cette chemise
yo pas aujourd'hui mon père vient
d'arriver vous avez payé pour voir mon
fils débuter son histoire sur des vols
dans un train en Russie pas pour la
millième fois c'est une histoire vraie
et il lui a fallu à peine deux secondes
pour commencer à me prendre la tête
regarde-le
êtes-vous la machine la fête c'est à
l'extérieur
de la valeur pour lui désolé s'il s'agit
d'une connerie de blague à la Tik Tok je
suis pas sûr de garder mon sang-froid
c'est une blague regarde c'est un faux
pistolet
ou pas alors tu vas venir avec moi en
Russie
[Musique]
happer
tu parles un peu vite tu sais pas ce
speed évidemment
[Applaudissements]
d'enfoirés qui est la machine le mythe
maintenant c'est moi qui mène le bal
la machine
je vais lui tirer une balle dans le
mollet
[Musique]
comment tu en as tué plusieurs des
hommes
[Applaudissements]